It's time to update
the Weather App again.
To store the list of cities that
the user wants to keep track of.
Here's what I want you to do, 1, take
a look at a few of the storage libraries
and pick the one that you
think will work best for you.
I've made some recommendation
in the instructor notes but
you can use anything you like.
2.
Add a function that will save the list
of cities the user has added and
hook it up so that it saves
whenever the user adds a city.
Third, update the apps so
that on start up it checks to see
if the user has any saved cities.
If it does, get the latest data for
those cities and update the cards for
those cities.
If it doesn't,
simulate the server injecting the data
into your app JS file and render that.
When you've completed this step,
your app should show the weather for
the default city,
for the first time the app loads and
allow the user to ad new cities.
But then when we load it the user
sees a list of cities that
they want to know about.
Be sure to compare your app to the link
in the instructor notes below and
make sure it works exactly the same.
And don't forget to try your
app in multiple browsers.
How does it work on Firefox,
Safari, or UC browser?